so there's a new propaganda war being
waged right now that was triggered by
donald trump's suspension from twitter
and is growing because of the distancing
that many for-profit businesses have
decided they want to make from the
right-wing social media app
parlor and i have news for everybody
who's furious
about what's happening to parlor woke
mobs are not destroying parlor
regulation is not destroying parlor the
government is not destroying parlor
hackers are not destroying parlor
capitalism is solely to blame for what
is happening to parlor
capitalism is responsible for parlor's
demise
apple and amazon have removed parlor
from their services
because as for-profit companies they can
do whatever the hell they want partially
because republicans have refused to
regulate them they are making business
decisions
that they determined are best for them
and they are making these
decisions within a free market in which
you and i as consumers can also decide
wow
i don't like what apple did to parlor so
now i'm going to boycott apple
or i can decide you know what i like
what apple did to parlor
i'm going to go and buy 10 iphones if i
want to do that
google decided to remove parlor from
their app store
because they say parlor isn't
sufficiently policing user posts and so
a whole bunch of posts that encourage
and incite violence and crime
are remaining on the platform and there
are people who
are furious and saying well hold on a
second google is kind of a monopoly so
how can you
say well if they're not on google uh
on the google play app store then you
can get parlor
because google has a lot of market power
well
where were these exact same republicans
when
elizabeth warren was saying we've got to
deal with the monopoly power of these
companies they were against it these
same republicans who now are saying
but but but they have monopoly power
they were against dealing with monopoly
power when we on the left
were sounding the alarm about the lack
of antitrust enforcement
which was allowing monopoly power to
grow
unchecked in the united states so
there's a real irony
in that unregulated capitalism and the
legalization of pseudo-monopolies are
responsible for the downfall
of this far-right social media platform
because the party
that has been asking for more capitalism
and more corporate freedom
got it and now they're furious that they
have that freedom
and it has led to a free market of ideas
and decisions
in which many companies decided we don't
want anything to do with parlor
nobody's preventing the people at parlor
from hosting their own servers and
paying for them that's how capitalism
works and
much like fox news is now being
destroyed by the monster
they created now that fox news is not
quite radical enough
for some people fox news is losing some
of their own radical audience to newsmax
and oan
that's the same mechanism that's at play
here the only question i have
is whether the right is pretending not
to understand this or if they genuinely
don't understand that
this is a circumstance of their own
making no one's first amendment rights
have been silenced here
everyone can say whatever the hell they
want
but there are for-profit companies
saying
we don't want anything to do with what
parlor is offering amazon isn't required
to provide hosting services to parlor
when parlor allows members to violate
the terms and conditions for amazon
hosting
amazon will lose money because they lose
parlor as a client
but that's amazon's call to make and by
the way let's go even further
anti-masters by the way being removed
from places of business by business
owners that's not government regulation
that's a company deciding what's best
for us is not to have anti-massacres
here
that's something they're allowed to do
dc rioters
being put on no-fly lists because
airlines have decided
they don't want their business or
corporations saying
you were at the dc riots you're fired we
don't want you working for us
that's the free market and lots of the
people crying about free speech
first of all don't understand what it
means and secondly
think that free speech means freedom
from
consequences to your speech the
consequences
to your speech in the free market are
part of free speech the speech and the
consequences are
all part of speech and remember that
when we want to talk about the first
amendment we have to be talking about
the government which is yet another
detail that seems to be missed here now
you are going to hear and in fact we're
going to talk about it in the next
segment
you are going to hear that all of these
companies are limiting the first
amendment rights of individuals
that these companies are engaged in
censorship
or whatever the case may be go back and
check out the interview
i did with a first amendment
legal scholar about the
misunderstandings that people have about
what that even means i know many of you
know it but in case many of you don't
check that out and let's now discuss
us continued misunderstanding deliberate
or not
on the tucker carlson program